[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to i'
like to know we are glad that you
decided to join us today uh we have uh
several very interesting questions that
we want to pursue in our uh class today
uh I want to give you the address where
you can send us your questions it's an
electronic address it'll be on the
screen
TVM tv.org
TVM tv.org we Delight when we receive
your questions uh we want to let you
know however that we get so many
questions that sometimes they have to be
put in line
if your question is not answered
immediately make sure that you continue
tuning in because we will get to it
eventually I have with me my good friend
and uh the coordinator of our Spanish
work here at Secrets un sealed at some
TV uh Pastor David Salasar thank you so
much for being here for our I'd like to
know today thank you Pastor it's always
a pleasure and a privilege to share and
study together the word of God praise
the Lord now uh before We Begin we want
to do what we always do and that is uh
raise a prayer to the Lord amen uh never
should God's word be opened unless we
pray and ask for the guidance of the
same spirit that inspired the word in
the first place amen so I'm going to ask
Pastor sasad if he would please uh pray
to the Lord that he will give us wisdom
today absolutely let us pray our
gracious Heavenly Father we are so
thankful that we can come to you to the
source of all wisdom and knowledge
and humbly request that Holy Spirit to
lead us into all truth to help us to
understand to bring to our minds the
things that you have spoken of and we
pray Lord that as we um share and
discuss from your word the answers to
the questions that our friends have sent
that it may not be our words or own
human opinion but it really will be your
will and your word speaking to them and
I pray all of this in Jesus holy name
amen amen
well our first question comes from uh
someone who I will not mention the name
uh it doesn't say where it comes from
but um it's a very sad question uh in
the sense that uh it reflects the pain
of a mother and um so let me read the
question and then I'll uh get some ideas
from you Pastor Salasar about what can
be done in this case absolutely uh good
morning pastors Pastor bore and whole
team thank thank you so much for all the
work you do for the Lord may he continue
to bless your ministry I am an Adventist
Mom married to a non-adventist I have
raised my children in the Church of late
my older kids in their 20s have since
stopped going to church but they still
identify as Adventists and study the
Bible however my younger one who is 13
has decided to pursue Catholicism after
doing her research she feels that it is
the only church that follows what God
wants us to do she disagrees with Solas
scriptura with the Bible alone and the
66 books only in the Bible I still take
her to an Adventist Church but she is
not happy there so this is uh very
painful even to read and I can't even
imagine what the pain of the mother uh
uh is this point so what can we say
about this to this grieving mom well
Pastor it is a very as you mentioned a
very sad situation a very sad experience
that she's going through some of the
things that come to my mind as I was
hearing the question and reading the
question is maybe there is obviously
this lack of the young L young girl the
13-year-old of truly know and understand
or identif
with what the Bible teaches somehow it
seems that she's been she's been allowed
to do her own research and obviously the
enemy wants to confuse her so she
probably has gone to I don't know
friends maybe her own father might be
also Catholic maybe that's what the
influence is maybe there's some family
members aunties Etc that are influencing
her
to sort of pursue other directions in in
religious things now
is kind of difficult when someone does
not want
to study the scriptures and allow the
scriptures to really direct the basis of
faith if she's not interested in really
taking the Bible as the source as the
pattern or as the way to really go to
the truth or find out what's right you
know all sort of things can come to
their mind um so I I think this is
something that I believe the mother has
to ask the Lord for a lot of wisdom in
regards to
sharing and trying to bring a a moment
of study together to be able to discuss
this together I want to kind of share
with her a promise from the scriptures
in regards to what the Lord wants to do
for children in the last days as I can
see that obviously the young girl has
not had an experience of conversion has
not really have has learned to see the
benefit and the beauty of God's word so
I think that we want you know I want to
encourage the mother to continue to pray
to to continue to um reach out to her
daughter and at the same time uh
remember this pre promise that the Lord
says in MA Malachi 45 and 6 it says be
behold I will send you Elijah the
prophet before the coming of the great
and Dreadful day of the Lord and he
shall turn the heart of the fathers to
the children and the Heart of the
children to their fathers as I come and
smite the Earth with a curse so there is
this promise that the Lord wants to do
and will do in the last days with
children who have wandered away who have
gone away that he wants to convert their
hearts and this is where really she
needs is a conversion experience now
what can the mother specifically do uh
the church is not attractive to the
lottery the church is not something that
she wants to be participate of you know
it's it's really presenting Christ in
her own life I believe the mother needs
to to ask the Lord to find ways to
connect with the daughter Maybe
emotionally in a way where you know they
can discuss what the Lord means to her
and and bring her to know that the Bible
is really all that you need to know the
Lord once you have that relationship
with God then you maybe can talk to her
about an experience of in theology in
the doctrine but unless she understands
and see the value of of Christ in the
love of the mom I think it's going to be
hard for her to really relate or find a
way to connect with her yeah I have
several questions that are not answered
in this question question right um who
is influencing her you brought that up
uh is it her father is her father a
Roman Catholic and is he influencing her
is she being influenced by what she's
researching on the Internet or is she
being influenced by her peers at
school uh it would have we would have to
find out what the source is right uh in
order to address it fully and
completely
um my question is has anyone sat down
with her to study for example the
prophecy of Daniel
7 that clearly identifies the Roman
Catholic papacy as the Antichrist of
scripture I mean I have a series that uh
is available uh if you download the app
right it's called God's prophetic chain
where I go through Daniel chapter 7 with
the time fine tooth comb and Daniel
chapter 2 and I give all sorts of
characteristic I think it's uh 11
characteristics that I give in that book
that prove Beyond any doubt that the
papacy is the Antichrist of scripture so
has anybody sat down uh to go over these
prophecies with her now the good news is
that if uh uh the mom is not qualified
to do this maybe she can find a pastor
who's willing to do it or maybe she can
convince her daughter to go uh to Su
tv.org and download the app and uh and
look at this series right I mean it's
irrefutable uh
furthermore has this young girl uh been
shown that the Roman Catholic Church
does many things that are contrary to
scripture and believes things that are
contrary to scripture so would God be
talking out of both sides of his mouth
saying one thing through the tradition
of the Catholic church and another thing
contradictory from the Bible no uh even
the Roman Catholic Church would say well
you know there's no contradiction but
the Roman Catholic Church for example
are we ready to pray to
Mary the Bible says that the living know
that will die the dead know nothing so
Mary is in the Tomb um are we prepared
to confess our sins to a priest the
Bible says that there's one intercessor
between God and Men Jesus Christ the
man uh does the bible tell us we're
supposed to keep Sunday is a day of rest
the Catholic Church might say that they
might say that they changed it where is
the evidence in the Bible there is no
evidence um praying for the
dead for God to get him out of purgatory
yeah I mean that's totally anti-biblical
um the idea of a hell that never burns
out where the wicked are burning and
burning and burning forever all of these
doctrines are not only not in the Bible
but they contradict the Bible has
anybody sat down with her and give her
given her the prophetic chain that
identifies the papacy because have
Babylon meal Persia Greece Pagan Rome
then the division of Rome then comes up
the little horn yeah which is the papacy
I mean it's it's not rucket science it's
simple but somebody needs to sit down
with her and needs to explain these
things so that she's able to make an
informed decision amen uh some people
are attracted to the Roman Catholic
church because it's big it's Rich it has
incredible music it has incredible art
they say the biggest has to be the best
but uh that goes against everything that
the Bible teaches yeah you know it's the
remnant that is always with the Lord
eight in the days of
Noah 7,000 in the days of uh the Days of
Elijah uh 1 and 12 in the days of Christ
yeah it's the minority that is always
correct because the majority basically
follows the flow yeah so I would
recommend that the mother um you know
download the
app and uh make sure that the daughter
is able to study that series God
prophetic chain uh also there study
notes that can be downloaded and uh pray
like she's never prayed before exactly
to ask the Lord to impress the heart of
her daughter uh because this is very
serious because Bible prophecy says that
the papacy is going to resurrect the
power and we see it happening these days
yeah and it's going to exercise Global
uh Force to force people to keep the
conic day of worship and we want the
daughter to be on the right side amen
amen anything else no I just to say like
you mentioned I believe the prayer of of
the mother she praying to the lord it's
so important I believe God will give her
the strength the wisdom the knowledge if
even she asked to be able to connect
with the daughter and really share with
her from the word of God I also worry
about the older kids that are in their
20s and have departed from the church uh
even though they're Adventists and
that's a good thing but at the same time
is is not good they're not actively in
the church so we got to encourage the
mother to continue to pray for them and
to continue to to see ask the Lord to
help her be a reflection of Christ so
that the children will know that true
religion is possible and that the Lord
can and will work with people and you
know help them to become more like him
so and I think the mom needs to show
special love for this daughter yeah that
she's really concerned about her it
doesn't do any good to try and Hammer
her yeah you know and say oh you know
you're wrong and you you're an Adventist
you know it it takes persuasion by Pro
providing the evidence absolutely in the
case abolutely okay let's go to our next
question this one comes from Michael uh
we're not told where it comes from
specifically uh this question has come
up uh before I've had other people bring
it up as well it has to do with the
godhead you know the Bible teaches that
there are three persons in the godhead
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
now here's the question it is well known
that in in the Heavenly
hierarchy we have God the Father God the
son and God the Holy Spirit first of all
I don't like the word
hierarchy you know uh the the Roman
Catholic church has a hierarchy you know
goes from the pope to the Cardinals to
the archbishops to the Bishops you know
and each one has more Authority than the
other uh you know in uh in heaven uh you
know God doesn't operate the universe
universe as a hierarchy so anyway it is
well known that in the Heavenly
hierarchy we have God the Father God the
son and God the Holy Spirit after that
we have Angel Gabriel who took Satan's
place that's confirmed by the spirit of
Prophecy mhm
however Ellen G white in her writings
somewhere in the great
controversy stated that Lucifer was
third in command after
Jesus where does this leave the Holy
Spirit who according to the hierarchy
should be third in command in other
words the Holy Spirit should be third in
command not uh Lucifer yeah or the
anointed cherub you know Gabriel yeah
the Cherub Gabriel yeah yeah uh where
does this leave the Holy Spirit who
according to the hierarchy should be
third in command please shed some more
light on this matter according to God's
word and the understanding he grants you
so what can we say about this question
uh where Ellen White says that um Jesus
was the uh Lucifer was the next in
command after Jesus thank you Pastor
it's important to know that the spirit
prophecy does mention that Lucifer was
the anointed cherub the appointed to be
next to Christ as far
as I guess in in responsibility if you
will but it does not mention the word
Third never mentions that he's third now
that not you know that doesn't make a
lot of difference but it does create a
little bit of a a clarification in
regards to the fact that she never
mentioned that he's third and uh then as
we understand if the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit are one and then came
the angels all the created beings which
is the case Lucifer and everybody that
has been created they had
the role
the position of being in the presence of
God and what Lucifer really wanted to do
is take the role of Jesus his desire was
to not be under Christ but to really
take the authority of Christ he decided
that was his his idea or his goal in
mind so in regards to the question as as
where you know the holy spirit is I I do
believe that the Holy Spirit had a
different role if you will was not a
role of commanding necessarily that's
something I think that we we can
actually see from this from the Bible
and the way that the Bible speaks of how
the spirit of God works it's a
ministering Spirit you know it's it's is
a spirit that serves is not necessarily
delegated to command and so anyway
Pastor maybe you can clarify more of
this but that's what I think this could
answer the question more directly well
you know Jesus we know that Jesus before
his Incarnation was the commander of the
Heavenly hosts right and the next in
command of the Heavenly Host would be
Lucifer Lucifer because Lucifer was kind
of like the deputy of Christ we might
say so in that sense G Jesus is the
second command and with regards to
commanding the
Angels uh uh you know the uh the I'm
trying to get my line of thought here in
in terms of uh the commanding of the
Angels right Jesus is the commander of
the Angels but his Deputy in heaven was
Lucifer and so Lucifer would be the next
in command after Christ in that sense uh
but there's no evidence as you mentioned
that the holy spirit is a
commander the Holy Spirit takes the
commands of Christ he does the work of
Christ so um the bottom line is that the
Bible makes it very clear that there are
three persons in the godhead there's the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit some
people don't like uh you know the the
names God the Father God the son and God
the Holy Spirit they say well Jesus
should not be called God the son but the
Son of God you know it it's really
irrelevant right uh he's the son of God
but he's 100% God and the Holy Spirit is
100% God and the father is 100% God now
when it comes to the Holy Spirit uh some
people say that the holy spirit is the
spirit of Christ or is the spirit of the
father uh but El white makes it clear
that the holy spirit is a third person
with his own individuality the problem
is he's a different kind of person right
uh and Ellen White says that we are not
able to explain the nature of the Holy
Spirit absolutely it's a mystery and so
and so I don't try to do that you know
we can know we can see the effects of
the Holy Spirit we can see the fruit of
the spirit in people's lives that's
that's how we know that the holy spirit
is working we can see the gifts of the
holy spirit in the church right but we
really can't Define exactly what the
holy spirit is um you know that's why
Jesus gave the example of the wind mhm
you know you can see the movement of the
leaves but you can't see the wind that
moves the leaves right and so uh the
holy spirit is a real person a real
individual person but uh the nature is
uh is not uh defined to us absolutely
the the concept of the spirit of God is
something that like you mentioned pastor
we cannot necessarily understand or
comprehend the nature of what who he is
and the Bible is not very clear neither
prophecy Spirit prophecy in what his
role was in heaven we don't not
understand that and the Lord has not
revealed to us uh what we know from God
from the Bible and spirit prophecies
that God gave
all power and authority to Reign and
command to Christ so Jesus is the as you
mentioned the ruler the king of heaven
and and he will you know you know be the
one in that will have all honor and
glory in eternity but where does the
holy spirit is in that equation we don't
exactly know and that's something that
has not been revealed more importantly
is to know that what happened with
Lucifer who who was in in responsibility
in command after Christ is that he
decided to take away the role of Christ
and be him you know the one that takes
his position and that's what really
brought that rebellion in heaven he
disrupted the order of things and so I
believe that's the main thing that the
Bible speaks of and so yeah okay we have
a few minutes left uh and uh this this
question I'm going to throw this
question at you okay uh yeah important
this comes from Angie it doesn't say
from where blessings in the name of our
Lord and Savior Jesus our Christ I would
like to know how many wives Moses had
was the midianite uh seph cifra and the
Ethiopian woman Miriam murmuring about
the same person now uh the question is
not really clear but I think that as we
reviewed it before uh before the uh this
particular session uh you shared uh what
you believe to be uh the meaning of the
question yes so what can we say about
that was Mo did Moses was he a bigamist
no the Bible and this is something
Pastor a lot of people sadly have been
hearing from Modern theologians they
think that M um that seph who was the
daughter of Jeff uh hetro the grand
father-in-law of Moses he was she was
from median and they think that in
numbers 12 verses 1 and two if we go
briefly there we see that the actually
Miriam and Aaron they spoke against
Moses because of the Ethiopian woman
that he had married so they think oh
this is not the same wife because of the
word Ethiopian but really that word is
uh is a is a word Kush in the Hebrew
it's speaking of a region that is
sometimes reflected to the regions in
Northern Africa or the South part of the
Arabian Peninsula right so because of
this people think or they assume that
they're different person but really is
the same person actually um Jewish
rabbis agree in the most part that this
is exact same person as uh Sephora now
Spirit prophecy makes this very clear in
Petri and Prophets page 383 it says
there though called a cushite woman
the wife of Moses was a midianite and
thus a descendant of Abraham so she's
mentioning here clearly that this is the
same woman Nei though she was called a
cushite woman she was from Midian which
was
seph and so uh in personal appearance
she defer from the Hebrews in being of
somewhat darker
complexion though not an Israelite seph
was a worshipper of the true God she was
a of she was of a timid retiring
disposition gentle and affectionate and
greatly distressed at the sight of
suffering and it was for that this
reason that Moses when on the way to
Egypt had consented that she returns to
medium so basically it's telling you
there that the this woman is the same
way one so is one wife that Moses had
not two not you know that different
person is exact same person it's just
that it's used in this way to describe
the complexity of her skin color a
little bit darker but other than that
it's really not saying that there were
two different persons so just one so in
short medanite and Ethiopian is the same
thing well not kind of it it refers to
the same general geographical look yes
and you know what actually just to make
this point very clear there's one verse
in habak 37 and that's that sort of will
help you know the individual who sent
this question to panji to to kind of get
an idea but in habak we actually see
this
description and uh hopefully I can get
the before or time Runs
Out Just Just say What uh well is just
uh it kind of connects both um and I'm I
am I am out of time but that's that's
one of those difficult books to find
unfortunately U it's it basically
connects the term medanite with kushite
so it's basically that's what it says
that's all it is well folks thanks for
joining us for I'd like to know uh
please join us for our next program
meanwhile may the Lord bless you and
keep you in his care see you next
[Music]
time